To best utilize Sequencer for creating linear animation, you must understand what the Camera
Cuts track is used for.
In a nutshell, the Camera Cuts track is responsible for binding specific cinematic cameras to
the level sequence, so Unreal knows which camera to render.
It can also act as a simple non-linear editor.
In our example, we have a simple two-camera sequence with a camera blend.
We're going to take this one step further by adding a third camera and a cut on the
Camera Cuts track.
Any time you start a new project, its success or failure largely depends on how organized
you are.
Sequencer is no different.
To start, let's make sure you have the 105.01 map properly loaded.
This is your level.
Go to the course maps folder to find the file and double click on it to load it.
Next, you'll need to make your working directory.
To do this, right-click in the course topics folder and select create new folder.
Since there is already a Camera Cuts folder present, make another folder and call it something
similar.
Double click on the folder and it will immediately open.
Next, you're going to need a level sequence.
Inside the content browser, right-click and go to cinematics in the pop-up contextual menu.
Select create level sequence.
Call this seq cinnyc underscore ex2.
Once that's done, double click on the icon and open Sequencer.
Next, you're going to need to create a new Cinic Camera.
Use the Camera Create button in Sequencer's toolbar and add the camera.
This will generate a Camera Cuts track and a spawnable camera.
Rename the camera cinicam underscore 01 underscore sh01.
You can pilot the camera by pressing the Camera Pilot button.
It will turn blue when it's active.
Next, you'll need to add actors to Sequencer.
Since the original 101 map doesn't include an SK mannequin in the level, we must find
one and place it there.
Go to the content browser and navigate to the assets folder.
Open it and then continue to the mannequin folder and inside that you'll find a character
and mesh folder.
You want the SK mannequin mesh in the mesh folder.
Click and drag this into your level.
Return to Sequencer and with Mani selected, click the plus add button.
Then go to add actor to Sequencer and choose add SK mannequin.
Once in Sequencer, right click over Mani in the Sequencer Outliner and convert the selected
binding to spawnable.
Next we need to add animation to the actor.
Since we'll be using animation sequences, we must remove the control rig.
Select the control rig and delete it.
Don't worry, you can always get it back later.
Next we'll want to zero out Mani's transformations in the details panel.
We need to do this because the motion capture data is offset by several units from 000.
Click on the plus button in the animation track and add the animation sequence called
ManiAnimTrack.
Mani should pop into place near the road sign.
Now we need to adjust the staging and shot duration.
This will extend our sequence length.
Click in the range slider field on the right and change the value to 350.
This is a little bit more than what we need, but we'll fix that.
Next enter the frame value in the time slider or scrub the slider to frame 256 and click
on the red right bracket button.
Our sequence is now 256 frames long.
To accommodate this, the camera cuts track must also be extended.
Grab the right side of the film strip and drag it out to the red out marker.
Finally, press the home button on your keyboard to center the timeline.
Now we need to create some additional cine cameras.
We're going to need a second and third camera so you can use the create camera button again
to create two more spawnable cameras and name them Cinecam02 underscore SH02 and Cinecam03
underscore SH03.
Once that's done, you're going to have to move your cameras into place.
Pilot your cameras 1, 2, and 3 into position.
Make sure you're using the pilot button so you can fly your camera directly into position
and frame accordingly.
Next, we must bind the cameras to our camera cuts track.
The first camera you created is automatically bound to the camera cuts track.
We need to bind the other two.
Shot one is approximately 52 frames long, so move your time marker to frame 52 and press
the plus button on the camera cuts track.
Select camera two.
Shot two runs about 130 frames, so move your time marker again and press the plus button
to add camera three.
Finally, you might want to make a decision regarding focus.
You can choose to disable your focus on all cameras to keep everything in focus, or you
can use the manual focus feature and the eyedropper tool to select Manny and keep him in focus.
Once you're satisfied, we'll move on to the final step.
To create a camera blend, right click over the camera cuts track and sequencers outliner.
Go up to the camera blend feature and activate it.
Now, go back to sequencer and click and drag on shot two and drag it over shot one.
This is going to take some experimentation to get right, but find your timing and choose
an option blending curve that meets your expectations.
To review your work, click on the camera icon in the camera cuts track and you'll see exactly
what the cameras are seeing in the sequence.
That's it!
Great job!
You've constructed your first sequence.
Imagine all of the possibilities you can now create.
Okay, it's time to move on to our final mod and discuss some recommendations.